[Music]
the 20th century saw an unprecedented
leap in human lifespan in the developed
world in America alone that the American
lifespan increased by 30 years that
doesn't mean everyone lived 30 years
longer it was mainly a function of more
of us surviving to adulthood but we have
gained an average of 10 healthy years in
whatever stage of life I'm in which we
don't have a name for because it's so
new I'm 66 this is an incredible
achievement right I mean we should
rejoice at this it is a remarkable
achievement of political stability of
public health in particular of better
medicine lots of things and yet the way
it is often treated by the media in
particular is as a disaster and partly
this is because people click on
disasters more than they click on you
know everyone chugging along just fine
or interesting demographic phenomenon
happened the most common shorthand used
for population aging is a gray tsunami
which conjures up a frankly terrifying
version of this wave of old people it's
poised to you know swamp swamp the
shores and suck all the socials benefits
and all the good things that we want to
leave to our kids and our healthcare
system
swamp them and suck all the good stuff
out to sea and that language is
misleading and wrong it is like the
alarmist language if you think about it
used to describe other demographic
threats like you know the Yellow Peril
the Red Menace right think about that
they this just amps up our fears without
a rational basis the fact is that
population aging in the United States is
the best studied demographic phenomenon
in history we have known for 66 years if
not more that the baby boom was coming
along that our parents had more children
that that my children represent another
mini baby boom the question is why have
we not done more to prepare wisely for
not just the challenge that this
represents but the massive opportunity
and the answer is that we live in an
ageist society we live in a society that
tends to frame aging as a problem
because if it's a problem we can be
persuaded to do things to fix it and if
it's framed as an illness and you often
see aging just equated with debility and
decline
whereas in fact it is also a period of
enormous growth and opportunity because
if aging is a disease we can be sold
stuff to cure it or to stop it you know
the only way to stop aging is to be dead
aging is not a problem to be fixed or a
disease to be cured
it is a natural powerful lifelong
process on which we are embarked at the
day we're born right it's not just
something annoying old people do or
celebrities do and it is something we
should celebrate
[Music]
you